Don't reserve this delicious bread for Italian meals;...
...it goes well with almost everything.
You will need: four medium garlic cloves, a half a stick of unsalted butter, softened,...
...one tablespoon of olive oil and a loaf of Italian or French bread.
Optional: four teaspoons of garlic paste or two teaspoons of garlic powder,...
...two tablespoons of chopped parsley sprigs,...
...and two tablespoons of Parmesan or Romano cheese, grated.
Step one: Preheat your broiler.
Step two: Mince the garlic cloves with a knife or put them through a press,...
...and then mash them with the side of a heavy knife blade...
...until they are the consistency of paste.
You can substitute one teaspoon of garlic paste...
...or one-half teaspoon of garlic powder per garlic clove.
Step three: Mix together the garlic, butter, oil, and parsley,...
...if using, until smooth.
Step four: Cut the bread in half, lengthwise,...
...and spread the garlic - butter mixture on both halves.
Sprinkle grated cheese on top if you like.
Step five: Broil until golden brown, about five minutes.
Did you know?
Since 1979, Gilroy, California has hosted an annual garlic festival...
...that includes a crowning of the Miss Gilroy Garlic Queen.